[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
maybe
what emotionally what i felt it's maybe
to be even more fragile as a disabled
artist
in general you know because you i feel
sometimes a bit insecure and i think
also my insecurity comes from there that
affect me a lot
and the contact with with the people
all the communications
all
about
has to do with cutter
to learn things
[Music]
i've noticed since i don't have to
travel kind of reduced stress for me
like
living in berlin
getting along like finding things having
to take the subway every day
that reduced so much stress
i will stick to my experience as a deaf
person covet gave me
like
the opportunity to face
which body i have
for example uh
people talking about something everybody
has their masks on and maybe i'm like
guys would you like to share word is
going faster than you
and word isn't waiting for you and i'm
not asking the world to wait for me i'm
just asking to do this simple movement
covey took
took off our bodies from this society
not just mine but even yours even able
body
everybody's everybody's body was taken
off the society because we were at home
we were locked down and blah blah it was
a moment in which i i really understood
my body
this part of my body and
without that pride coming from telling
people i'm deaf i don't know which kind
of art would have done
[Music]
you